This.
This is one of those moments
you got to ask yourself,
what kind of life do I want
the world and build for guys like us?
That's
why we got to take whatever we decide
is on us.
My phone calls,
right hand, try to push me out.
What are your seeing?
What I can do
if you step out of line?
You know, once
I guy you, like a fish.
You imagine
the people saying my name on the streets
after you're gone
and it means something.
The new kingpin of Gotham.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
This will be my new Batman Penguin trailer
they just dropped.
The series is coming in 2024 next
year, so I'll explain what's going on.
How this connects with the Batman movie
franchise.
Like the Batman 2
that they're filming right now
in James Gunn's big
reboot of the DC movies.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I will do episode videos for the series
just like I did for the Peacemaker Series
is sort of like the next in the long
line of DC doing their big budget.
HBO series, kind of like
Marvel is doing the Disney Plus series.
The only difference with this,
as you probably guessed from James
Gunn's explanation earlier this year
when he announced his big reboot projects
and what the timeline is going to be
is that the Batman franchise with Matt
Reeves and Robert Pattinson will be set
in a completely different universe.
They'll consider it
official Elseworlds like
there are a couple elseworlds projects.
This is one of them.
It's one of, you know, our jobs
mine and Peter's is to come in
and make sure the DCU is connected in film
television, gaming and animation,
that the characters are consistent,
played by the same actors,
and it works within one story.
And if something is outside of that,
like Matt Reeves, Batman
or Todd Phillips, Joker or Teen Titans go
that it is clearly labeled
as DC Elseworlds outside of the mainstream
DCU continuity.
So James
Gunn is just letting Matt Reeves do
whatever he wants
in his own different universe.
So all these characters
aren't meant to be connected
to what's happening with the new Batman
Brave in the Bold movie,
which would be a much older version
of the character with Damian Wayne.
It connected to all those other movies
and series that he's
considering his gods and monsters
like DC Phase one, DC Chapter one.
They're calling it
the way they describe the series, though
it's sort of like Colin Farrell
doing his version of Scarface,
but with the Penguin character,
I came to Penguin and the idea of Batman
when Burgess
Meredith played
Penguin and Adam West played Batman.
Me his character is kind of like Scarface.
He's totally underestimated.
He knows he can be more shallow.
To my left, it's meant to pick up a week
after the first Batman movie ended,
which is why most of the city, Gotham
City, is still underwater
and FEMA is still there.
Like you see, the FEMA truck in the city
in after the death of Carmine Falcone.
It leaves this power vacuum
within the Falcone crime family.
In his family, like his daughter
and his son, are a big part of the series,
as is Salvatore
Maroni, played by Clancy Brown.
Of all people. It's going to be amazing.
So Penguin gets into this mad dash
for power to fill that power vacuum,
take over the Falcone crime family,
and it sounds
like he'll be fighting his widow,
as well as his daughter and his son.
Carmine's daughter is Sophia
Falcone, played by Cristin Milioti.
You probably recognized her from a million
other things.
Just based on the synopsis, though,
in the footage in the trailer,
it sounds like she's also going
to be Penguin's love interest.
So they'll have a very complicated
relationship
where she's low grade
fighting him for control of the family.
But he's also trying to hit it
throughout the entire series.
Carmine
Son is also a big part of the series.
Alberto Falcone
It sounds like he'll also be vying
for control of the family
as well on his own, like
so this is a three way battle
for control of the family.
But you also see Penguin coming to meet
Shohreh Aghdashloo, and her men seem like
they're about to kill him,
so she seems very powerful.
She might wind up
being the widow of Carmine,
or he might be Salvatore Maroni, his wife.
So the using the series to develop
more of the mob element in Gotham,
we saw a lot of it
during the first Batman movie,
but there are a ton of characters
that they didn't feature.
Like,
we only saw pictures of Salvatore Maroni.
We didn't actually see him in the flesh
because they cast Clancy Brown
and you don't cast him in
just one off light roles.
It sounds like he's
going to be the main antagonist
to Penguin during the series, like it's
about a bunch of terrible people.
So the Penguin is going to be
the protagonist of the series.
You have to put him up against someone
who's even worse, even more powerful.
That would be Salvatore Maroni,
who will be trying to get out of prison
now that he found out what Carmine
Falcone did, basically informing on him,
throwing him under the bus,
even though all the mob members in
the city, all the different crime families
were part of the money laundering scheme.
With the Gotham City
Renewal Fund set up by Thomas Wayne,
you also had the idea that the Batman
will be after Penguin as well,
watching him like a hawk, like a bat,
if you want to think of it that way.
Technically, bats don't see so well.
They use echolocation.
Even though Penguin in Batman worked
together like Penguin helped Batman.
Find out what was going on with Carmine
Falcone.
Penguin kind of informed on him.
It took Batman a little while in the movie
to actually figure out what he was
really telling him, but he was telling him
without telling him outright,
like the call has been coming
from inside the room the whole time.
Carmine informed on everyone
he was the informant the whole time.
You notice
Penguin drives a purple Maserati?
I guess
because it's Italian we're talking about.
The mob here seems a little on the nose
to make more penguin jokes.
The way that Matt Reeves
described his character
during the events of the Batman movie
because it was meant to be Batman
Year two,
the Penguin character was still meant
to be one of Carmine's lieutenants,
not that powerful, but he still controlled
the Iceberg Lounge,
which you also see him going back
to during the trailer.
And because this is after the disaster
that was caused by the riddler's bombs
and the flooding in the city.
And that's all still going on.
You see the wreckage of the sign outside
like the club is still in tatters,
but it's still there.
I love the way they end the trailer,
though, with him using the Kingpin
reference because we've been talking
about Daredevil coming back in the MCU.
They're filming the Daredevil Born Again
series over in the Marvel Universe,
and Kingpin is going to be running
for mayor during that,
the kingpin of crime in the city.
But that's basically
what Penguin is saying.
He wants to become the kingpin of crime
in Gotham City, the de
facto leader of all crime families,
not just the Falcone crime family.
Me, I almost comment on what was on
the World
and everything in it.
Matt Reeves also said
the series is supposed to bridge
the gap between the first Batman movie
and the Batman two,
which is just calling the Batman
to right now.
The rumored villains of that are Mr.
Freeze.
They've also talked about Clayface.
I believe Matt Reeves said
that he wants to eventually
do all the classic Batman villains.
So they'll just get to all of them
eventually.
Robert Pattinson is supposed to guest
star on the series.
There was some question about the TV
rights for Batman and how that was
all working out with Disney, because
technically they own the Fox Network in.
Fox had the right to do
Batman on the Gotham Series
that they did a couple of years ago.
The way James Gunn explained
that it's not an issue.
They can do as much Robert Pattinson
Batman during the series as they want to.
So it sounds like
he'll be in a couple episodes,
probably a little bit as Bruce Wayne
in a little bit as Batman.
But like I said, most of the series
will be about Penguin seizing power
within all the different mob families
in Gotham in the wake of this disaster
and trying to deal with Salvatore Maroni,
who will probably find a way
to get out of prison
and then go after him and try to seize
control of all the crime families himself.
Within the history
of this Batman universe.
They actually explained that's
what happened
the first time around with the Gotham City
Renewal Fund and how Salvatore
Maroni was thrown under the bus
when he went to prison.
Carmine Falcone basically seized
all the Maroni crime family's territory.
And now that Salvatore
Maroni is getting out, he's
going to try and take all that back.
So big mob war
coming to the Penguin series,
but it's basically Oswald Cobblepot
becoming the truer version
of the classic Penguin
that you remember from all the previous
Batman movies that take a little bit later
in their timeline.
A lot of you now
asking what's going on with the Riddler
and Barry Wilkins Joker character.
There's still an Arkham Asylum
that's supposedly the next spin off series
that Matt Reeves is developing.
They didn't say
when that's going to premiere,
but that'll feature more of Batman's
rogues Gallery of villains.
I'm guessing that might drop sometime
after the Batman two winds up releasing.
So every couple of years we get a new
Batman movie with Robert Pattinson.
In between those,
we get the series to bridge the gap.
Pretty much anybody from the movies
like Catwoman, obviously Jim Gordon,
the Gotham City Police characters,
anybody else that you saw in the movies
is Fair game to show up on this series
or the Arkham Asylum series
so the Riddler could come back
during this,
Even Barry Wilkins
Joker come back during this, too.
The big reminder, though,
is that this Robert Pattinson Batman
in any of these characters
will not cross over into James Gunn's Gods
and Monsters DCU connected Universe.
So when we get to the Batman Brave in the
Bold movie, it'll be all recast versions
of any characters that they use
that are similar,
like a new version of The Joker,
obviously a new version of Batman.
It sounds like
it's going to be a couple of years
before we get to that movie,
so it'll be a long time
before people have to worry about that.
For a while,
there were rumors that Ben Affleck
was going to come back and direct
like he might direct Batman
Brave in The Bold,
but then Ben Affleck was like,
Hell no, I'm not coming back.
Now there's rumors that Andy Muschietti,
who just directed
The Flash movie, is actually going
to be doing Batman Brave in the Bold
because literally everyone
at Warner Brothers
and anyone who has seen the movie already
claims it is like the greatest movie
to ever hit cinema.
If it really does wind up doing
as well as people say it's going to do,
then expect Andy Muschietti
to direct other DC movies inside
James Gunn's Gods and Monsters.
We'll see who winds up directing that
next rebooted Justice League movie.
Like, would it be James Gunn?
Because he's doing Superman Returns?
Or will it wind up being Andy Muschietti
because it sounds like he wants to direct
the Justice League movie, too.
I'm sure there's going to be
a ton of questions
about what's going on with the series.
We'll probably get a much bigger trailer
later this year, so of course I'll do
more videos for when we get more footage
because HBO Max is rebranding is just Max.
Like they're just changing the name
a little bit.
They announced a bunch of other
new TV series with a bunch of teasers
and trailers, like
there was a Harry Potter reboot trailer.
I'll do a video for that.
And then there was a Game of Thrones
night of the Seven
Kingdoms trailer
for the Next Game of Thrones.
Spin off.
I'll do a video for that as well too.
While you wait for everything, everyone
click here for my brand new Blue
Beetle trailer
with another Batman reference
and click here
for my full Mandalorian season
3 episode 7 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.